(bright music)
- Bob Epstein is a remarkable person,
he is a Berkeley product,
he has a PhD from Berkeley,
he has undergraduate
degrees from Berkeley,
he had a PhD in engineering,
he has an undergraduate degree
in music among other things?
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
A minor in music, okay,
so a minor in music.
And what's neat about Bob is that
he is a technological innovator
so he was present at the
creation of relational databases
and also SQL language which of course
is a really important step
forward in trying to find ways
to store and access data.
So he's a technological innovator
but he's also an entrepreneur.
So he started a company
Sybase which helped
implement that technology and get people
around the world using it.
And then thirdly, he's also
a policy and entrepreneur
and a person who's put
together all these things
and come up with new ideas about
how do we can make the
world a better place.
And in that capacity, he is co-founder
of environmental entrepreneurs called E2.
And E2 was very instrumental in helping
to lay the groundwork
for the passage of AB32
which is the path-breaking legislation
that's really put
California at the forefront,
it was respect to energy conservation
and changing the way we think
about using energy in the world.
So Bob has been a technological,
a business entrepreneur
and also a policy entrepreneur.
And I think that's very Berkeley,
that's the kind of people
we produce who can do it all
and who put all those things together.
And as you'll see here today when he goes
through his presentation, he drool upon
all of those talents
in the work that he did
to try to think about
how to change the way
we approach energy and how we try to deal
with the problems of climate change.
So Bob is also by the way a member
of the Goldman School Board of Advisors
and we're really lucky to have him.
He's been very helpful to
us, he in fact was the person
who helped start on the
way to our third building
that we're building, just nearby,
where the parking lot is behind me.
And Bob helped me sit
down with a spreadsheet
and explained to me what was going on
with financing a building like that
and helped us figure out how to do it.
And so I give you Bob Epstein
who is really an extraordinary person.
A person who has brought
lots of thinking thought
in just lots of new ways of
approaching policy problems
and who will tell you about
that today in his talk.
So Bob Epstein.
(students applauding).
- I have mine.
Thank you Dean Brady, I
appreciate the nice comments.
This talk has a long origin
but having looking at a 10
year anniversary of AB32,
it was passed in 2006 and in 2016,
the goals were achieved four
years ahead of schedule.
How many governments do that?
Of course many do but it's always good
when the local government can do that.
So I tried to look at, well,
so what did we think in 2006
and what really happened?
'Cause that's an interesting point.
So I'm going to spend a
little bit of time on that.
But then given all the
climate news that happened
in the last year, I'm gonna talk
about how we get to 1.5 degrees.
How we don't exceed that
target and more importantly,
what's the role of
California and all of this?
What should we be doing and not be doing?
I'm gonna give you lots of opinions,
a bunch of facts, feel free
to challenge all of them.
But before I get started I
wanna recognize two people
that were very much part of the bill.
And that's Adrienne Ovod here.
Adrian was Fran Pavley's
legislative person on the bill
and kind of they had
person behind the scenes
that we worked with.
I guess every day if not every hour
for a year or so (laughs).
And then Diane Doucet who
also was instrumental in this.
One thing you'll learn is
sometimes it's easy to pass a bill
but it's hard to implement it.
So in the first two
years, that was the time
when the opposition was gonna
try to take the bill apart
and Diane was instrumental in organizing
the business community and still is.
She's not looking at me though
but that's as Diane right here.
(students laughing)
So I just I rarely get a chance
to acknowledge these two
amazing people in person
in front of an audience on recording.
So it's now permanently known
(students laughing)
and of course if I say
anything out of line,
they will immediately correct me.
Now a couple of surprises in here,
there'll be a surprise every 15 minutes.
(students laughing)
Now you'll probably all wanna
know what the surprise is
and it hasn't, it's only
been 10 minutes, right.
So I'm not really covering
the science of climate change.
However, a very good
friend of mine has written
the world's best book on that topic.
It's called the Global Warming Primer.
It's by Jeffrey Bennett,
he's at the University
of Colorado in Boulder.
I brought six copies, every
15 minutes approximately,
one will be given away.
(students laughing)
There's a hidden jury in
the room that will decide
when a question or a comment
or even a facial expression
rises to the level of worthiness.
(students laughing)
At that point one of the
books will be given away.
For the rest of you, I thought
maybe six people would come,
otherwise I would have brought more.
(students laughing)
For the rest of you, I'll
give you the reference.
But this not only explains the science
and easy to understand ways,
it also explains how to
refute the climate deniers
and all of the claims behind that.
So it's quite a quite a good read.
So that's the background.
So let's dig in.
So we'll start with the good news.
So the goal of AB32 in
2006 when it was approved
by the legislature in a bipartisan manner,
that was a Republican, that voted for.
(students laughing)
Was to get...
Just testing to see if
you can hear me (mumbles).
But we'll cover that,
there's actually a stronger
bipartisan support now than
there was at that time.
The goal was by 2020 to get emissions
back to 1990 levels or lower.
So you can see on the chart here,
a California's GDP, our
economic growth kept going up
during this whole period.
It actually grew faster than
the United States overall.
Population grows steadily in California,
40 million now is about 38
million when we started this,
greenhouse gas emissions dropped
and of course the divisor here,
greenhouse gas emissions per capita
and per GDP continued to go down.
Hurray, right, that's great news.
You can applaud.
(students applauding)
Okay, and just to make a fine
point on this that in 1990,
we were at 431 Million
Metric Tons of emissions
in the state and in 2016, we're at 429.
So the details of this, are all
in the Air Resources Board inventory
that was printed last summer.
And so I felt like I
should have put together
a list of references
and I forgot to do that.
So I will do that and give it to Borah
and make it available.
But that's the source of this data.
So let's look at what actually
worked in this time period.
The first of all is electric power
through renewables overachieved.
What we thought would happen.
So in this time frame, we're
now up to six gigawatts
of wind capacity, 10
gigawatts of utility solar,
five gigawatts of rooftop solar.
So you can see that the
electric power curve
in terms of emissions
has dropped, you know,
started peaked here in 2008,
started steadily dropping,
it's dropping very quickly now.
So that's I would say, it's
a clear over achievement.
And I'll show you later that solar
with storage and windless storage
is now cheaper than natural gas.
So that's an important scenario behind it.
If we look at liquid fuels,
there's a program called
the LCFS, the Low Carbon Fuel Standard,
of course you already all knew that
but I just thought I'd prove to you
that I knew it stood for also.
And what this required is that
the greenhouse gas content
in fuel had to drop by 10% by 2020.
The way that's measured of course
is in grams per mega Joule.
Now you all know furlongs
per fortnight for example,
as a unit of measure,
so grams per mega Joule,
gram of CO2, a mega Joule
unit of work in the vehicle.
It's a way of normalizing
all vehicles and everything.
So you have a way of
comparing heavy duty trucks
to you know, light duty cars.
So this was also a huge
success in terms of reducing
the greenhouse gas content
of the fuel, that was good.
California has always
been good in efficiency,
so that was a great success.
Transportation fuel usage was pretty good
while oil prices were high.
And then oil prices dropped,
will show you what that looks like.
The other thing that really counts here
is 10 years experience of
taking an entire economy,
the fifth largest one in the world
and figuring out how to operate it
and regulate it and make it all work
with all the moving parts.
That's huge, there are very
few places know how to do that.
And the other thing is 14
years of political support
for something that takes 50 years to fix.
By alternative, you could
think of health care.
Well the support moves in and out,
so having a stable political environment
and during this time period
the entire legislation
turned over because of term limits.
Maybe there's somebody still
left who has voted on in 2006
but I can't think of who it is,
So it's a complete turnover and that.
So all of the legislators could say,
that was somebody else who did that,
that's not my bill.
So we had, and we'll talk
about how we dealt with that.
So that's what worked quite a bit.
Okay, anyone wanna ask the first question?
Alright, well that 15, oh yes.
- [Student] Is there any research
into why the transportation
first (mumbles)?
- Yes, there is, I'll
show you that very soon.
But because you're willing
to ask the first question,
you get the first book.
Congratulations sir.
(students applauding)
Okay the ice has been
broken, you know it's safe
to ask any question you want.
Okay, so if we look at
Californians emissions by detail
and you could spend a
long time on this chart,
let's first talk about the big bars.
Transportation is the largest source
of emissions in California.
It's about 40% and it's not
getting a lot better quickly.
In that you can look at
the biggest portion of that
which is passenger vehicles.
So I think there's 1.6 cars
per licensed driver in (mumbles).
It's some number like
that, it's more than one.
There's a lot of people driving,
either because they like to drive
or because there's no
alternative to get to work
or you can't afford the housing
so you buy a house in Tracy
and you drive to San Francisco every day.
So there's plenty of reasons
why there's a lot of
passenger miles in California.
That's a big part, the heavy-duty trucks
is the other big part then there's some
rounding errors on the top.
If we look at electric power
in this time frame of 2016,
then when you have in- state power
and then you have the
out-of-state imports coming in.
You know we're down to 1% coal,
so it's mostly natural gas and renewables
and nuclear which we'll
talk about a little bit.
There's still 10% there.
Then you have all the industrial sources,
the refineries being
the single largest one,
you have industrial manufacturing,
the extraction of oil and gas.
Sometimes it's hard to
remember that California
used to be the third
largest oil producing state
in the United States
behind Texas and Alaska.
Anyone remember who bumped us off
and moved us in the fourth?
Ah c'mon this is an easy one.
And now think north.
(background voice drowns other sounds)
There we go, alright.
So North Dakota in a 10-year period
totally outstripped us through fracking.
We'll see if they like it when
they're done but that's it.
You have other things like landfills.
And then an interesting factoid
they'll be really great at
your next cocktail party,
do you guys do cocktail...
Probably don't.
(students laughing)
I'm sorry, I showed my age.
Cement, if you took all
the cement production
in the world and made it a country,
it would be the third largest
greenhouse gas emitter.
Go to it, you'll have a great
time at your next party.
Yes, you have a question?
- Okay, so the question is,
why is transportation so large
when there's so many ways
of making it smaller?
Okay, I'm gonna let Adrienne answer.
No answer (laughs)
(students laughing)
I'd say there's a couple
of reasons to look at it.
One is California historically has had
very poor public transit infrastructure.
And if you start out with very poor stuff
and then you try to put it in afterwards,
it's incredibly expensive
for the land value.
So if I look at something like BART
which is the only way
I get to San Francisco,
somehow that managed to happen
but that was the last major
transit project I can think of.
If you go to San Francisco and
you look at Van Ness Street,
they're trying to put in
a bus rapid transit lane,
they're in their third
year of construction
but just to take a
little bit of the street
and make it two lanes for a bus service.
So I think if you don't start
out with the design for it,
it's very hard to add
it in after the fact.
That's the first reason,
the second reason is oil
used to be, you know, it's
an oil-producing state.
So oil here was plentiful,
all the refineries were here.
It was a great thing to
do and the main problem
with transport originally
was smog and pollution.
So that was that started to be addressed,
so I think starting from behind,
now we'll talk about how
you fix it going forward.
But I have no apologies
for California except
when you start out without
thinking about transit,
it's very hard to add it in afterwards.
And my dad who's the city planner,
I grew up in Stockton in the middle there,
he showed me his, he had two master plans.
One is where you do a plan and you design
for regional growth and the
other is where you don't,
you say people will be
buying houses in Tracy
and commuting in San Francisco.
I said, dad, that's the
stupidest prediction
I have ever heard.
And I've apologized them
for years after that.
Okay, looking at the other items,
they have agriculture and forestry,
the largest one being livestock.
Now for those of you who have any doubts,
the main source of
emissions from livestock
comes from the front
end, not the back end.
Another important cocktail
joke that you might need.
Okay, a residential commercial,
this is the use of natural gas
for heating or for cooking.
And then you have them not specified,
we won't talk about it.
so that's where the source...
Yes.
Now, if we look at
solely, first the Question
is whether residential has
dropped in this time period.
And what this slide shows is that--
(background noise drowns other sounds)
So there has been some improvement
between the combination of
commercial and residential.
If I was going to predict,
I'd say most of its...
I don't, I could find a detail
but not while everybody's watching.
You have some mixture there.
The other thing is that
any new construction
typically picks up in an efficiency.
And so if houses get more efficient,
they use less natural gas for heating.
You also have efficiency and
well the air conditioning
would show up in another column.
This is somehow related to a drop
in the use of natural gas
most likely through efficiency
but I would have to look
at the actual report
to give you an accurate
answer to that question.
Okay, so let me talk about
what wasn't part of the plan
that influenced the results.
So these are all things,
they're not good or bad,
they just happened and
they influenced the result.
The first was macroeconomics.
If we look at where
the drop really started
to accelerate, it was in 2009.
So if you damage the economy,
there will be less economic output,
there will be less use of resources
and you will see a drop in
greenhouse gas emissions.
It's not a great plan.
(students laughing)
But it does happen and
the reverse happens.
If the economy is doing
better than your model,
then if the economy is going faster
than you're cutting emissions,
you will see the reverse trend as well.
So that's the first point, the second is,
at the time of passage,
if we look back to 2006,
you know, we're dealing with,
we're getting close to
$100 a barrel for oil
and it peaked at a $160.
Well at those prices,
all sorts of other things
become affordable and people
think less about buying an SUV.
But when it starts to crash
down like this and the other,
the whole buying, the whole shift
in what sort of vehicles
people buy has shifted
back to trucks and SUVs.
So cheap fossil fuels
at least with the effect
of these an odd diesel but of crude oil
had a bad effect.
Now you have something like fracking.
So fracking just by
itself made natural gas
cheaper than coal, is
straightforward to use it
instead of coal, so
effectively what killed off
the coal industry in the
United States is dead.
It's dying, it's dying at a steady rate,
that hasn't changed in years.
We'll talk about some attempts
by various government entities
to try to change that,
none of that's worked.
Natural gas is so cheap
that that was a huge benefit
behind it but it also works against you,
it sort of says well,
in order for renewables
to be competitive they had to
be cheaper than natural gas.
So that set the bar for
renewables even harder.
Now you have things like weather.
So in 2016, there is huge amounts,
you can probably remember
how much it rained
if you were here, there's a lot of rain
and a lot of snow, a
lot of really good snow
the powder none of that sierra cement.
So there was abundant hydro and so hydro
comes with no emissions.
On a drought year you
don't get that benefit.
And then you have weird like
the largest refinery was
shut down due to an accident,
was offline for a year.
Well that really cut emission
but that's not something you can count on.
And then the most amazing thing
at the start of this time,
California had 20% of its
power coming from nuclear.
Now I'm not going to comment on whether
that's a good or a bad thing
but from the perspective
of a running start, that's
20% with no emissions.
Half of it, the San Onofre nuclear power
was shut down in 2012, yeah
in 2012, yet we still made it.
The other half, a Diablo
Canyon will be shut down
in 2025, is that right?
So that will have gone from 20% nuclear
to zero and still made it,
and still overachieve
the emissions target.
So my point behind this, is
you can plan all you want
but the external factors can be 50%
plus or minus behind this.
So none of these things, if
you had asked me to predict
the price of crude oil, I
would say well, you know,
no one can do that but I'll
say $200, instead it's 50.
If you look at the price of natural gas,
well it was $8 per unit.
When this bill was passed,
I said well at that rate
you got all these things
that are competitive,
it drops down below two dollars.
So thet have these huge factors going on
that weren't part of the plan.
Yes, okay the question
is whether federal policy
influences the true price of it?
Absolutely, as does the avoided cost,
the social cost of carbon.
So that there are a lot of
factors that you can look at
and you can see studies to
look at these various things.
I'm just showing you what the results
were in terms of
emissions and those prices
are the wholesale prices
that people purchased
not their true costs.
Does that answer your...
I mean that's--
(background noise drowns other sounds)
I have two hours with the
material and an hour left.
So I'm not gonna try to answer that
'cause I'm really not
well-prepared to do it (mumbles).
I mean your point is valid.
So let's look at what's
the history in California
in terms of major laws.
Now the point I wanna emphasize here,
every one of these things
is a performance standard.
So if we look at the first ones, Nox,
not just oxygen emissions from vehicles.
That was the start of
regulating the tailpipes.
Before that, your car could put anything
it wanted through its
tailpipe and it could aim it
at any direction, at anybody.
And if you got too close
you got really sick.
And if you stayed far away
your whole air basin got sick.
So these are performance
standards that said,
this is exactly how much
of each of these toxics
you're allowed to emit.
And if you exceed that, you
can't sell in California
even if you're VW, we'll get you.
(students laughing)
Okay, now in 1977, partly in
response to the energy crisis
that happened in the early 70s,
California started setting
standards for appliances.
Those have had a huge impact behind things
and again their standards they say,
the emissions for this
size your refrigirating
you can't use more than
this much electricity
or you can't sell it in California.
Now for the most manufacturers,
if you can't sell it in California,
there's not worth making a non Californian
and a Californian version.
So they just made it becomes,
many of these things are
become a national standard.
The next year we started
building efficiency standards
also known as Title 24.
So that said, if you're
building something new,
there's a minimum threshold that you have
to be at in terms of efficiency.
Then in 2002, not that long
ago, was the first time
we actually created a
renewable portfolio standard
which guaranteed a market
for, and I'm gonna call it
affordable electricity,
seems really expensive now
but it was the starting point behind that.
Then in 2002, California
started the with climate change
And the very first bill that
I've ever worked on in my life
and Fran Pavley when she was a freshman
assembly member worked on 2002
as the California clean cars bill,
it said a standard for how
much greenhouse gas emissions
could come out of the
tailpipe of a vehicle
through a long involved process
and a change in presidency,
eventually became a national standard
and that's where we are today
with a couple of minor exceptions.
2006, then the global
warming solutions Act
was enacted by the legislature.
Skip ahead ten years and we're
starting doing the renewals.
In Fran Pavley's last year,
in office due to term limits
as a senator, she passed
SB32 just a coincidence
that it has the same
number I've been told.
And that set standards for the year 2030
in legislation to be
40% below 1990 levels.
So that was the next standard.
But the most important
thing about that bill
was it got the legislature on record,
the current legislature
is saying we are behind
dealing with climate in California.
The next year we established a legal,
secured the legalness
trade system of a price on carbon.
Prior to this bill, there was
at least a legal ambiguity
whether the original legislation was legal
or included the ability
to set a price on carbon.
The Air board was sure that it did,
many lawyers were sure there did
and the oil industry was sure
they would eventually prove them wrong.
So by passing this bill that took away
all of the legal risk behind it,
it also got eight Republicans on board,
enthusiastically on board.
So it changed the dynamics,
the political dynamics by saying,
this is a broad accepted targets
that we're trying to do, it isn't narrow,
it isn't just the enviromental caucus
which is much smaller now
than it was 10 years ago.
If we look at this
picture, there's Gray Davis
signing the first bill, there's
me when my hair was black.
(students laughing)
There's Fran Pavley, Josa
Midian, many other other friends.
So for those of you at the Goldman School,
I'm saying there's nothing
more satisfying for me
in my life, besides my family,
if I go the next step on behind it,
of when the California
cleans cars bill was passed
which is my first time ever
trying to work on something
and I looked down the hallway
at the auto industry representatives
and they were, you know,
they weren't bummed out,
they were paid to do their job,
it didn't get it done, they'll
still be employed whatever.
And just thought about
what was accomplished,
it was the best feeling ever
and I hope you all experience
that multiple times.
That's my wish for all of you in policy
'cause that's why you're here.
Okay, so now I'm gonna move to the future.
And first of all, we're gonna
start about the one sentence,
definition of the strategy
for the energy sector.
As we saw, there's lots of
other sources of emissions,
decarbonize electricity and
electrify everything you can.
That's the strategy, okay.
So let's look at where this came from.
If we back up and this chart is taken,
this is not a non-government
chart, this is from the Lazard
and this is an attempt
to look apples to apples
at all energy generation and
try to compare them equally.
So it's called the
levelized cost of energy.
It says, "If you're gonna
build a new facility
and run it for 20 years,
what are all of your costs
during that 20 year period
including the fuel?"
So you have to forecast
what natural gas will cost
or what coal or nuclear,
what the cost of capital is?
So it's an attempt to take everything
and put it on the same playing field.
So people who argue over these things,
argue over the assumptions but the idea
is to try to make them all look the same.
So if we look at this item right here
which is utility scale
solar, it starts out at $359
in 2009 and it ends up down here at $50.
These are measured in per megawatt-hour.
So it ends up down here at $50.
If we look at wind, it had
less distance to travel,
started at 135 comes down here to $45.
Now the nearest competitor
is efficiency gas combined cycle.
So this is natural gas
and a combined cycle large operations.
It hasn't changed much.
It (mumbles) $83 10 years
ago and it's $60 now.
It's not that the
equipment got any cheaper,
it's natural gas drop in price.
And you have to look at what
the forecast is going forward.
Now let's look at coal, it's a $102.
So if you had to decide whether
you can build a coal plant
or a solar, and I realized
they're not the same thing,
we'll come to that in a minute,
it's coal is twice the price.
Now, if we look at nuclear,
it's higher than that.
The reason why is the
incredibly high cost of capital
and the incredible high uncertainty
of whether you'll ever finish it
because in the history United
States in the last 30 years,
there hasn't been a new one finished,
there have been some started.
This is the state of things in 2017.
Now that has an interesting effect.
It says that there's been
now five gigawatt hours
of rooftop solar.
So let me show you what's
called the duck curve.
Now first of all, can anyone tell
why it's called the "duck" curve?
(students laughing)
Who can?
Who can tell me why?
Yes.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
That's right, that's right.
(students laughing)
We have another winner,
round of applause for the young lady.
There we go, there we go.
(students applauding)
Nice job, now let's look at this "duck"
in a little bit of detail.
If we back back up to 2013
and this is looking at
a typical spring day in California
and this line looks at demand.
So you know, it starts
out at 19,000 megawatts
and it runs through most of the day.
And then near the end
of the day, it goes up
because people turn
their air conditioners on
when they get home.
Now what happens when
you put rooftop solar
on your house behind the meter?
You know, if you're on the
other side of the meter
and you're the independent
systems operator,
it looks like demand's dropping, alright,
'cause all it knows is you're drawing
less demand from the grid.
So that's what happens here,
so if we look at the
actual curve here on 2017,
actual usage, if we look at
the amount of electricity
(mumbles) being used in
California is up here.
But if we look at how much
was being drawn from the grid,
it's down here hence the "duck"
as you correctly identified.
Now what happens around five six o'clock
when it's not dark yet
but your solar panels
are no longer directly in the Sun,
the sun's at a lower angle,
the tree has come and blocked you?
Well, suddenly you see this huge demand.
So for the last three hours,
suddenly have this three hour ramp,
you have to get 13,000 megawatts
from somebody in a hurry.
So there's a couple
issues with renewables,
there's three basically.
The first is that demand
and generation are shifted.
So you have to account
for the shift behind that
and I'm gonna show you how about Hawaii
has done to solve that
problem, they have sun there.
That's one problem, the second is,
that sometimes you can have a storm
that will go on for a week
in the middle of winter
and the wind is too high
to run the the windmills
and there isn't enough sunlight.
So you've got to go...
So you have two storage problems,
one is the time shifting one
and the other is that there's
just no power anywhere
and people want the lights on.
So those are the two, I
said there were three,
but those are the two big
issues to deal with in solar.
So of course one of the
answers is battery storage.
So let's look at Hawaii.
Now Hawaii's a great example
because prior to solar
and wind, a 100% of Hawaii's electricity
came from what fuel source?
Who can read this slide?
Quick, diesel.
Right, 'cause it's just like
the North Slope of Alaska.
If you want to have electricity,
you have a diesel generator
and that's how it gets done.
Well how much diesel is
locally produced in Hawaii?
Very close, probably zero.
Okay, so it all gets shipped over
and I'll guess done there.
So it's incredibly expensive,
so just the cost of the fuel
for diesel is about 25 cents in Hawaii
to produce one kilowatt.
Now to run that 100 watt
light bulb for 10 hours
cost you 25 cents in fuel.
So if we look at the most recent project,
this was announced January 8th,
there were seven solar projects awarded,
260 megawatts of solar but
it comes with 16 gigawatts
of storage, they handle the time-shifting
and a guaranteed price
between eight and 12 cents.
So solar with storage in Hawaii
is 1/2 the price of the alternative.
What's the probability that Hawaii
will be a 100% renewable?
Will the first state 100% renewable?
Well, I'd better book on that
and I have three left so are four left.
So I can afford to do it.
But this is a good
example where if you have
a predictability of things and
you have a high initial cost,
the transformation is there already.
If we look at every other
state having to do it,
you've got different cost equations
but that's what you need to do, yes.
Okay, so the question is how
do they guarantee a price?
They guarantee that
price and they guarantee
a minimum number, a minimum
amount of generation
based on the average amount of
solar radiation in that side.
And then they downgraded,
they assumed that
there'll be some decay.
And so they'd come up and say,
well, we can guarantee you
this much at this price
and the advantage of solar
is, what's the fuel cost?
Zero, so you have your capital investment,
you have the reliability equipment
and you have the Sun predictability
and you have 50 years worth
of information on the Sun.
So it's a very low risk that come up
with this guarantee, yes?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Okay, I'm not an expert on Hawaii
but I doubt that there's any natural gas
'cause you would have to bring it in,
there's probably propane.
So if you're like me and
you really wanna cook
on something other than electric,
you'll have a propane stuff.
So there's probably still propane
coming into this state, yes?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Yeah, okay.
It would have had to, it's
the all-in cost to build it.
So it would have had to
include some prediction
on subsidies but as you know,
the production tax credit expires.
So I would be willing
to bet that they assume
you get the subsidy until it expires.
And then nobody's gonna
take the political risk
that it'll be renewed.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
They would change a
little, yeah they would.
They would but now this is looking at
a levelized price for 20 years,
so I doubt it would change much.
Those prices down there
would have been affected.
But the subsidies certainly played a role.
Okay, so let's talk about
moving forward here.
And look at what California
is gonna try to do
and then how do we get this done.
So if we look at where we
are right now in, you know,
2016 is the last full year of data,
we've got a four year head
start on the next target
which is gonna be helpful
because, see how that line
looks a little steeper than the last one.
so the line from 1990, the
line to get to the 2020 target
was about a 1% per year drop in emissions.
The line from 2020 to 2030
is a little over 3%
drop emissions per year,
something we've never
done without a recession.
And that Air Resources Board
did not plan a recession as
part of their scoping plan.
(students laughing)
So you've got a that target moves you down
to 260 Million Metric Tons.
And that's on the path
for the two-degree target.
If you wanna match the
IPCC target of 1.5 degrees,
then we'd have to drop
down to 249 instead of 260,
not a huge difference for California
assuming you can do that.
The other thing is the
original 2050 target
was not in legislation but it was an edict
by then Governor Schwarzenegger
of get it to the 80%
below 1990 by 2050, which if
you include population growth,
is actually a 90% cut.
The IPCC has said we
need to be zero by 2045,
so Governor Brown in his
last couple of months
made that the target if
I remember correctly.
So this target has moved down to here,
that target could move a little
but those are the targets.
So let's look at what's
called the scoping plan.
So what California does is
every two years produce,
and the last one was in
2017, a scoping plan.
This was published in November.
This lists all of the (mumbles),
what all the targets are,
what all the measures are,
what are the risks
associated with each one?
What's the economic analysis?
And then that becomes the guideline
and then they do regulations
to match the scoping plan.
So I borrowed this, this is page 21 or 28
from the scoping plan
and this is looking at
over that 10-year period, the
aggregate amount of reductions
in different categories.
So if we look at this, here's electricity
going to a 50% renewable,
it's 16 out of this big number, 660.
The reduction in transportation fuels,
not in transportation,
just the fuels, it's 25,
energy efficiency will add 64
mobile source improvements 64,
then you've got these two huge categories,
217 from the short-lived
Climate Pollutants.
This is trying to reduce
the methane in California
and also the high potential
ones that have the long names
that I can't pronounce but (mumbles)
I wrote them down, so you'll
see the names in a minute.
And then 236 from cap-and-trade.
So this is where my problems start.
So let me give let me just
give you two scenarios, okay?
One scenario says we can
guarantee the reductions
but we have no idea what the prices are.
The other is we can guarantee the prices
but we have no idea
what the reductions are.
Which one do you want to vote for?
Right.
(students laughing)
So you want to kind of...
Who said neither?
- [Student] Me.
- Oh, alright, that was
exactly the right answer.
So here we go it's been 15 minutes.
Alright, round of applause.
(students applauding)
Here go, come on,
(mumbles) congratulations.
Okay, gotta ask more questions.
Okay, so they're both
horrible alternatives, right?
So what California is trying to do
is split the difference.
It's saying, the direct measures
we know exactly how
much you have to reduce
or you can't do business in California.
And those have all generally
worked out just fine.
Then there's the other measures which is,
well we don't know how you're gonna do it,
but you can only emit this much.
And if you can't figure out yourself,
find somebody who can
and buy it from them.
So that's the general
notion of cap-and-trade.
So 236 getting the largest single category
from something unknown is quite a risk.
So I'm going to talk about
how we do you risk that.
But the other thing is right now
if that's trading at $15 a ton,
how much are Californians willing to pay?
And at what point do you find out?
So I'm going to show you how
to think about all of that
and that'll give you some
idea behind my own thinking
of what the solution looks like.
But let me give you...
So I've decided I'm gonna give
grades to all these things.
Alright, so if I look at,
does California have the
technology and the policy
to do the scoping plan,
here's how I would rate it.
I would say for renewables,
the 50% target in the scoping plan
will actually be met 10 years in advance.
So I'd say that one we
can over achieve on.
The low carbon fuel standard
has already been increased from 18 to 20,
there'll be an announcement
at 5 o'clock today
that the Biofuels Association believes
we could eliminate all
fossil diesel by 2030
and so they're releasing a report
to show how that would be done.
So I think those two can be done.
Appliance and building standards,
we've never had a problem doing them.
I mean it'll work out.
So those are, yes, now the likely category
means I didn't thoroughly research it
but I talked to people I trust
and I kind of think it'll happen.
So the high potential greenhouse
gas reductions will happen.
I'll talk about the Kigali
agreement in a moment.
I think those are very likely,
I'll explain what they are
but these are the pollutants
that caused the ozone hole,
got replaced with pollutants
that don't damage the ozone
but are highly, highly
greenhouse gas damaging.
So those have to replace one more time.
The methane emissions, I kind of think
we'll know how to do that 'cause you know
where to find them, you can smell them.
Okay, you can deal with it.
And then energy storage, I think
enough has happened already
that that'll find its way in.
So I'm gonna put all those
in the likely category.
Then we've got the unclear, how do we go,
like your question earlier,
how do you get more
reductions in transportation?
'Cause this isn't nearly enough.
How're you gonna get
reductions from cap-and-trade
'cause that's a pure economics,
and we'll talk about that.
Then Forest Management
which is not in the plan,
agriculture and pasture land
management is not in the plan,
in the scoping plan
except as aspirational.
So all those are unclear
which leads me to the
main point of my talk here
besides the congratutory point is,
so where the wrists
and how do we fix that?
So the biggest unknown is carbon pricing
and this is the thing that
gets the most attention
and the least emissions reductions.
So let me talk about it for a minute.
First of all in the original scoping plan
leading up to 2020, it
was only a backstop.
What it meant is the
direct missions reductions
from renewables cleaner fuels etc,
were enough to meet all of the targets.
But what if we were
wrong about one of those
where the idea behind
cap-and-trade was to say,
well then, all those major emitters.
And there's anyone in
this room a major emitter?
Come on, you can tell
me, I'm trust (mumbles).
Alright, do you how
much you'd have to emit
to be a major emitter?
About 25,000 tons.
So that's the target.
So if you can find all those people,
there's about 500 entities in California
that emit that much or more.
No one in this room does.
So you can go after those, you
can really tighten them up,
you can you can work on
it and if all else fails,
then they have to buy
the emission reduction,
they have to buy an
allowance to emit a ton
and there's only so many allowances.
And then the price was set at $11 to $15
in this range to have a minimum price.
As I mentioned in 2017, this whole program
is reauthorized under the tax code
which enables the
legislature in their wisdom
to use the proceeds from
this from anything they want.
Anything from a high-speed trade,
from Fresno to Merced,
which will drastically
reduce emissions in that area
'cause they won't have to fly any more
between those two cities.
I made that up, right.
Okay, you know I'm just kidding.
(students laughing)
Okay, no need to write
that down, it's not true.
Okay, but they can do anything
they want with that money,
there is no requirement,
there's no standard that says,
you have to get this many
tons out of this money.
It is money available.
The other thing I was
added was a ceiling price
strongly recommended by
Severn Bornstein who,
congratulations, was just
appointed to the Cal Board
which is great news for him
for Cal and for California,
very excited about that.
The reason for a ceiling
price is there is a price
at the emissions trading at which there
the political support disappears.
And the way to tell where that price is
is if we look at a $10 per
ton, each $10 ton for emission.
For carbon adds about 10
cents to a gallon of gas,
it adds about 0.5 a cent to
natural gas energy generation,
it adds one cent to coal
and it adds zero cents to renewables.
How much does gas have to go up
before the public gets outraged?
Well, generally it's about 50 cents.
So if that suddenly went from $15 to $50,
there'd be public outrage,
the Legislature would whip into action
and they'd say, we're
gonna fix those regulators,
those unelected bureaucrats
who have decided
to choke the California.
You can just imagine the frenzy
and how the excitement
of this war speech is
why that happened.
So somewhere between $50 and $65,
my feeling is that's where
the political support
drops below majority.
So in fact the ceiling price was added
but because there was fear
of saying what it was,
it was deferred to the Air Resources Board
to decide what the ceiling price is.
So this gets back to the question
that was so aptly explained that,
I don't want either earlier.
Above a certain price, we no
longer care about emissions,
we just don't want the price any higher.
The number has not been announced yet
but I'm gonna guess it's $65,
I'll be happy to do a
raffle on that price.
At $65 you can buy as many
allowances as you want.
So at $65, we stop
worrying about emissions
and we start worrying about the economy.
Below that number then we're happy to see,
just take our chances
and see what happens.
So that's how California compromised.
But if we look historically
at where carbon pricing
has actually caused emission reductions,
it's in what's called offsets.
So California has defined five offsets;
Forestry, Urban Forests, Livestock,
Ozone Depleting Substances
and Mine Methane Capture.
If you do one of those according to SPEC,
you are allowed to sell that reduction
and the people who buy
it are the oil companies
'cause though they offer, they buy those
for 90 cents on the dollar.
So they could do spend
15 to buy an allowance
or they could spend $14 and buy an offset.
So what the floor on a mission
I'm pricing actually does,
is it creates a market for offsets.
And and that's what's actually happening.
So the expectations from the scoping plan
is starting in 2023.
We'll start seeing
reductions from cap-and-trade
and by 2030, there'll be
60,000,000 tons in that one year.
Okay, so now let me back up
and say what's California's
mission in all of this.
The arguments will be California's about
is the fifth largest economy,
so in 2017 which is
the last available data
I could verify, you had these numbers.
The USA was 16.6 without California,
California was 2.7 behind
Germany, Japan and China
but we beat out France and the UK.
We used to be behind them, not anymore
and we know what the UK is trying to do.
So I feel pretty good about that.
So we're the largest economy,
fifth largest economy we
should behave like one
and be responsible, that's one goal.
The second is to be the
resistance to Washington
for a good sport if not
for good policy reasons.
And then we get to the
real things going on here.
The innovation not just
technology but policy
'cause what we have to do in California
if we wanna address the
global climate problem
is we have to demonstrate there is a way
of eliminating the greenhouse gases
without damaging the economy.
If we can do that, there is no reason
why other countries won't and other states
and sub nations won't follow us.
If we demonstrate, we
can cut greenhouse gases
by making the quality of life worse
and shrinking the economy.
No one's gonna pay any attention, yes?
That is a great question,
so the question is,
if we're trying to encourage innovation,
why are offsets encouraged?
And the fact is that's an ongoing debate
and if you're an emitter,
you're limited to a
limited number of offsets.
But if you ask the Air Resources Board,
what they would say is, we're regulators,
we're not omnipresent and
knowledgeable of everything.
So part of the idea is
to create some markets.
So if somebody can figure
out some way of doing it,
it isn't the Air Resources
Board to figure out
every possible thing that could be done
and decide which ones are good.
So they created categories and
as people came up with ideas,
if they could demonstrate they're real
and they're additional, then
they qualify as an offset.
So it's a way of allowing innovation
that is not driven by
government, if you will.
And it's a limited amount,
so it can't be everything,
it's a smaller amount.
And there some people think it's worked
and some people think it's a sideline
and it's not worth fighting over anymore.
I think those are the kind of the ranges.
So the other thing we're gonna do
is we wanna do knowledge transfer
to the rest of the world.
So if you look at like
the state of Oregon,
they've just adopted our policies.
If you look at China,
the majority of policies
in China started in the United States.
There's a regular exchange there.
If our only job was to get
to California and China,
to these targets, I feel
really good about the chances.
Say whatever you want about China
in terms of human rights
and the rest of that,
when it comes to policy and
the rest of these items,
they're highly motivated
because their economy
is held back by pollution.
So when you're in that situation,
you're willing to invest
a lot behind this.
It's also a country that's, you know,
I think the average politician in China
has an engineering background,
the average one in the United States
tends to be more legal behind it.
So it's a different, it's obviously
a totally different culture
but in terms of adopting
California's policies
and being a great partner
on looking at these things,
they've done some amazing stuff.
They are the largest producers
of electric vehicles.
One of their new company,
one of the spin-offs
a new company is making
the electric buses,
they'll be the largest
supplier, they're in California.
So the innovation behind what's
happening all those things
is quite dramatic and it's
an amazing, amazing area.
So we wanted the knowledge transfer.
We wanna win with the lowest
possible price on carbon.
And this is where I
have most of my debates.
There people are saying, let's stick it
to the oil companies, let's
make the price really high.
Okay, there's a reason why
Exxon wants a price on carbon,
they just pass it through
everybody will have to pay it.
We're gonna come to that moment.
So let me move ahead,
and let's start first
with the federal government.
So here's a model the federal government:
Denial, Delay, Disaster,
Drench and Repeat.
This is the summer and fall season
in the federal government.
And the question is, what
has an eye but cannot see?
So my strategy on the federal government
is resistance through
2020, mostly through legal
political climate, the political
climate changes behind it
and in 2021, there's major federal action.
But if you're gonna have
major federal action in 2021,
you need to decide in the
next two years what action
you would actually wanna have
which I'm gonna talk about, yes?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Yeah.
They're powerful but, you know,
one of the things that happened right,
they got in all this trouble
and then they've got nationalized
and then we passed all these
laws which they agreed to
and then we set them free again.
I just think they're a different world now
and I think they do see a
lot of money and opportunity
if they ever get batteries affordable
and sell electric vehicles either.
So I think I think of the oil industry
as a bigger problem
than the auto industry.
And I see Adrian nodding,
so you generally think...
So I'm gonna repeat that
so everyone can benefit
who's listening online, both of them.
(students laughing)
So it's because it's a global market
and if we look at what's happening
in Europe and Asia and elsewhere,
there's huge demand on
more efficient vehicles.
And on electrification of vehicles
and you even have some countries banning
the internal combustion
engine which I would never do
but they're doing that.
So they have all that pressure already,
they don't wanna risk the tea leaves
by betting on a total reversal.
On the other hand, the oil
industry is a different problem,
so I'm gonna focus on them in that.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Okay, the reason why is, that's
picking winners and losers.
So to ban the internal combustion engine
is to bet that no one's
going to figure out
how to make a liquid
fuel that's carbon free.
And why would you want to ban that
when there's all these people
working on it currently?
I mean there's huge investments in that,
they've had some success,
some failures behind it
but someone might figure that out.
Someone might figure out how to convert
sunlight to hydrogen.
You can go directly from
hydrogen to liquid fuel
and it's got a lot more density
than all these batteries.
So why would you eliminate that
possible technology thread?
I mean what benefit is
there from eliminating it?
You could say that cars have
to be zero emission behind it
but right now the electric vehicle,
it's emissions are somewhere else.
Now they're just not with
you, they're somewhere else.
Alright, so you could
say that the standard
is the emissions from an electric vehicle
and you have to meet this in your fuel
and then you haven't eliminated.
So that's why I think
those countries are wrong
but they didn't ask me,
they should have maybe, yes?
(students laughing)
Okay, so the question is,
are there disadvantage
to all electrification
behind in terms of transmission
lines and other things?
There may be some, it's not anything
that I'm not knowledgeable about it.
But it's kind of like
if somebody discovered
that cellphones really
weren't very healthy,
how many people...
At some point, no one's
going to turn them in.
So it may be with electricity
that we don't think it's a problem
but I don't really have a good answer
of what that risk is.
Yes, in the back.
Okay, so I just want
to repeat the comments,
it's a really important one.
If one of the studies I was
involved in is looking at
the year 2050 and the general strategy
is all the new electricity demand
coming from the vehicles
would more or less
be offset by improvements in efficiency,
so the overall demand on the grid
is gonna not be dramatically different
in this timeframe but how it distributes
and how it all works is
is the real challenge.
Okay, so let's look at some of the things
the federal government has been
doing lately, just for fun.
Every morning I get up that
there's something interesting
to do, I capture on a slide
and then I hope to use it
but I never have enough time.
So you saw that coal and
nuclear are too expensive,
like way too expensive.
Well there's a solution to
that, let's subsidize them.
So Rick Perry who didn't know that nuclear
was part of the Energy
Department until he took the job,
that's just a political
comment but it is true,
I have my source verified there.
He came up with this
idea of subsidizing them
and having everybody else pay for it.
He took that to the took that
to the Federal Energy Regulatory committee
which voted it down.
So we think it's gone
for a while (laughs).
Anyway but it might come back.
So that's one idea.
Then you have people
like the City of Oakland
or the state of Washington
refused to export coal.
So if you're a coal
producer in United States
and coal demand is
dropping, your only hope
is to send it somewhere
else but to do that,
you have to ship it and you need a port.
So those are all turned down,
so Trump announced the plan
to use the military ports to do this.
It won't happen but that's
kind of what you deal with
on a regular basis.
So I heard one of these almost
for every day of the year.
(students laughing)
But let's talk about the reality sucks
but we all expected it.
So last year had a 3%
to 4% jump in emissions.
Well duh, if you're not
driving reductions fast enough
and you have a huge economic goose
that happens in the first
six months, guess what?
Emissions go up, so you
could have modeled this
and predicted it to two digits accuracy.
So that's not, I mean it's a problem
but it's not a new problem to have.
Okay, half okay let's
look at some other things
that happened and then we're
gonna move to the solutions.
So this is a great headline,
this was from October,
if I remember correctly.
ExxonMobil gives a $1,000,000
to promote a carbon tax and dividend plan.
So Larry Summers, is a smart guy said,
a company getting behind
its product being taxed
is a very rare thing.
Do you agree or disagree?
(students laughing)
- [Students] Agree.
- Agree, okay, good.
Okay the plan also includes
a regulatory simplification.
What does that means?
Well, an end the federal
and state tort liability.
So if you're an oil company
and you've known for 50 years
that your product is causing damage,
are you concerned or not that
may be someone's gonna sue you
and some courts gonna decide
you're actually liable, strict liability?
Well the answer is absolutely yes.
What's the solution?
Well, we think you
should have a carbon fee
and we should do some
regulatory simplification,
there we go.
Alright, so that's an
announcement from October 8th.
Okay, the other thing that happened
at the very end of session
is the energy innovation
and carbon dividend Act HR 773
was introduced on November 27th.
The session ended early January,
the bill has not been reintroduced.
But it did introduce
a concept bi-partisan,
there is this the citizens climate lobby,
is anybody here a member?
It's a great organization,
they've been working for years
to try to get a policy like
this enacted in Congress.
One of their other ideas
is to have a climate caucus
at the federal level,
yeah, but the way it works,
is a Democrat can only join
if a Republican comes in.
So they had in equal numbers of both.
The idea is a carbon fee at %15 initially,
goes up ten dollars a year for 10 years
and if it solves their
problem great and if not,
will revise the plan.
Okay, the carbon dividend and the money
that's collected is not spent
by the federal government
but it's sent back per
capita to all citizens.
There's also something
really important in this,
a carbon Equalization tariff which says
if you're a country whose price on carbon
is not at least at our level,
the carbon content of your product,
how much emissions occurred
to create your product
and ship it here well,
there'll be a tariff
equal to the carbon.
And that solves it, it
creates an incentive here
in another country, you wanna ship here,
if you had a carbon
fee at least like ours,
then you'd have no tariffs
if not your products are disadvantaged.
This is just a fabulous idea
and there are lawyers who think
they would hold up from the
World Trade Organization.
There's also a regulatory adjustment
which means that EPA could
do nothing for 10 years.
There's a similar bill in the Senate,
there'll be a bunch of these,
that are happening this year.
Here's my problem with
it, is if I have to bet
my grandchildren's
future on a fee on carbon
causing behavioral changes
and in 10 years from now
finding out whether it works or not,
I'm not willing to bet on that.
I would have this but I
wouldn't have this by itself.
So let me tell you what else I would do.
And by the way in the
midterms unfortunately
half of the climate caucus
Republicans lost re-election.
I went through the list,
I don't think anybody
had to deal with climate,
they just happened
to be in districts that were competitive.
So there's an interesting
thing there, sideline.
Alright, so here's some new thinking
we're gonna try to cover.
First of all can the oil and gas companies
be made part of the solution?
And the way to think about this,
is we're in the year 2045,
we're celebrating zero emissions
what business is Exxon in?
(background noise drowns other sounds).
I mean it's a rhetorical question
but if we don't have an answer for that
or ideas behind that, I think
the goal is how do we get them
into the lines of business that we think
and needed by then, that's a good fit.
It's no longer we're at the point
where we have the luxury of saying,
let's just drive them out of business
and somebody else will hire those people.
So then we have the Kigali agreement
which I'll talk about Carbon Farming,
Rethinking building materials
and converting carbon
to something of value.
So and when I look at
California's targets,
I'm totally uncomfortable
with cap-and-trade at $60
getting those emissions.
So I'm trying to figure out
what else could we be doing
and I'm gonna spend a few
minutes on each one of these.
So let's look at the future
businesses for oil and gas.
This is a thought experiment,
these are the businesses
they're currently in.
Now let's take carbon pricing,
sometimes the price on
carbon is just enough
to get them into oil business.
There's policy drivers and
then there's the unknown
which is litigation which
I think has to ramp up
really really hard and fast
you put all those pressures on
but you want to pressurize them in a way.
Oh, there's a great quote
that Dean Brady once told me,
as an old quote about Standard Oil,
they said they've done
everything in the Congress
except to refine it.
(students laughing)
So we have to take these refiners
and turn them into a productive
part of the solution.
So if we look at one of
these things might be
one is renewable power generation,
a few of them have moved
into that a little bit now.
Can they decarbonize?
Can they take natural gas?
So this gets back to the problem that
when you have bad weather for a week,
your batteries ran out six hours ago,
how do you keep the lights on?
Well the cheapest way to do that
is to use the existing infrastructure.
The US has six months worth
of natural gas storage.
If natural gas where the
backup, we could go months
without any renewable.
So no one thinks we have to
go more than three weeks.
So if you could decarbonize natural gas,
well, the way you would do that
is you take the natural gas,
you'd split it in the
hydrogen and carbon, co2,
you could store the co2 you
somewhere, take the hydrogen
and you can burn it directly
and make electricity.
So would we like them to
be in that line of work?
Well, they know how to
handle a natural gas,
they have pipelines, they
know how to move it around.
So I think part of the thinking has to be
what businesses do we want them to be in?
And what pressures do we
need to apply so they move
to those businesses
sooner rather than later?
So this is just the thought
of a thought experiment
that I'm working on for the next year
with various people to say,
how do we make them part of the solution?
Now Shell, after the Paris
climate accords came out
did a model that said,
this is how you could meet
the targets and but it includes
some very deep negative
emissions meaning carbon
that's taken out of the atmosphere
done primarily through
a mixture of biofuels
and taking biomass, taking plant material
and getting the carbon into the ground.
The fact that they did this
scenario is interesting,
it doesn't mean their
business is moving that way
but it gives you, reading
through this gives you a clue
to their own thinking of what
businesses might they be in.
Now not all businesses are the same,
this gets your question
of, is the auto industry
the oil industry the bigger problem?
Marathon petroleum is
the largest distributor
of liquid fuels in the United States.
And you probably have all
heard of the Coke brothers.
So you have this article in December 16th,
The Oil Industry covert plan that changed
the car mission rules.
They went to the Trump
administration and said,
you know, fuel efficiency used to matter
when we were buying oil
from dangerous places
but now the US as of October
is the largest producer
of fuels in the world, and
you know if you by country,
So we have all we need,
so there's no reason
for these anymore, why
don't you just relax them.
The auto industry wasn't a big fan of this
'cause they're already working toward it
and they already want to
promote electric vehicles
but the oil industry
went behind the scenes
and are trying to muck this up.
That's just shows it won't be easy
but the part that intrigues me the most
is this litigation by the
state of Rhode Island.
So the state of Rhode
Island is not an island
but it is on the coast, just
quick geography refresher.
Okay, and they are suing 50 oil companies
not necessary all the right
ones but 50 which is a start.
Okay, they're claiming
that due to sea level rise,
they've suffered damages,
the oil industry knew
that sea level rise was a direct result
then we know exactly
what their emissions is,
we know how to convert
emissions into sea level rise
assuming Antarctica
doesn't fall into the sea
or any other major ice things.
So they want damages to
pay for infrastructure.
There's a very good legal
standing behind this.
Now the trick is that the oil industry
tries to move this to friendly courts
but the states can keep
it in a state court
which is more friendly to our costs.
It only takes one major
thing to try to change it.
So I think putting pressure here
but what will happen is that all companies
will go to congress and
then say, we need relief,
you know, you you provided free insurance
to the nuclear industry,
whatever, we need it too.
So the trick is in the
next two years to know
if they could do that how do you stop it?
Now the way you stop it,
you'll notice that Tobacco
they went to Congress for
tobacco and asked for protection
and they didn't get any.
Now I believe the reason why
is 'cause every state gets money
from the tobacco settlement.
So there aren't probably
aren't two senators
that wanna mess up their state's income
to do a favor for a tobacco company
that's not even in their state.
So I think connecting the dots on this
and getting more states involved
is a big way of a new
way of putting pressure
on the oil industry.
But you have to know when
they come to complain,
what you want them to do.
Let me talk about two
other things quickly.
So the Kigali agreement, Kigali's.
This goes back to the Montreal Protocol,
I would say it's the
only successful example
of a global environmental
policy structure that's held up.
And I guess the reason why
is 'cause the ozone hole is
you know, it's a small
number of pollutants
that caused the problem a
small number of companies.
But anyway, the Kigali agreement
amended the 1987 Montreal Protocol.
It went into force January 1st, 2019.
Now it's phasing out hydro fluorocarbons
that replaced the original
chlorofluorocarbons.
My understanding of this
is the chlorofluorocarbons
then damage the ozone.
The hydro fluorocarbons
don't damage the ozone
but they just happen to
be 1,200, 1,300 times
more potent as a greenhouse gas than co2.
I guess you could say whoops!
Alright, so the goal
is to fix this problem,
it turns out the
alternatives already exists
and it's mostly, the
alternatives are mostly made
by American companies.
So you have this interesting
thing that the EPA in 2015
you know, rule that we're
going to move in this direction
and guess who said the EPA overreached?
Probably somebody you've never heard of,
a Judge Kavanaugh, there
you have heard of them.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Well that's interesting,
I wonder if that predicts
the future, who knows.
But then you have this amazing thing
the US Chamber of Commerce said,
the Kigali agreement is
a win for the environment
and for the US economy.
150,000 jobs in the next 10 years,
13 Republican senators still in office
signed a letter requesting that Trump
if only he didn't know
that it helps the climate,
maybe it wouldn't be a problem
but I don't see any reason
why this can't get done.
You've got a great alignment behind it,
it's a huge benefit.
The state of California
has an estimate of how much
this would help us and it
makes air conditioners.
Using the alternative,
can be 30% to 60% more
efficient so it cuts...
It's just everybody wins.
So that's a hopeful thing
and you could imagine
that happening in the current Congress.
Carbon Farming, this is one of
the new areas of opportunity
the state has recently
increased its objectives
to work in this area.
And the basic idea is the farm
in a way that keeps soil there
and keeps carbon building up in the soil.
So the California current targets
are 15 to 20 million metric tons by 2030.
The state just recently
released a new analysis
that doesn't say how to do it
but says the target should be doubled.
There's a bunch of researchers here at Cal
that are trying to
figure out how to do this
but some examples, one
research paper that I looked at
called 147 million metric tons by 2030
could be safe well that's half
of the problem right there.
There's lots of other states behind this
but the main point is they're
getting agricultural products
and this is part of the next 10 report
that just came out looking towards
a carbon neutral California.
You just can't do it unless you start
to look at the natural systems
and get them more involved.
So carbon farming is one way to do that.
Another way to do that is to
rethink building materials
so total self shameless self-promotion,
everybody understand the rules.
Okay this is a company I've invested in.
The ideas you can
actually make wall systems
out of certain types of bamboo.
When you do that if you
look at the lifecycle
of bamboo in three to six
years of grows to maturity.
And then you cut off the
stock and guess what happens,
three to six years later,
another one comes back.
Let's look at Douglas Fir,
well he cut it off, the stamp has to decay
and nothing happens
unless you actively do it.
And then it grows back in 50 to 100 years.
So the opportunity using timber bamboo
and it turns out the environmental
properties are better,
everything is better behind it.
Could we switch a huge portion
of the wood construction
into two things, one would be bamboo,
the other advantage of
bamboo is if you create
more demand for it, you
can grow bamboo forests,
you can replant them and grow them back
where they were cut down
in a couple of years.
It takes an unknown amount of time
to restore the Amazon,
if it even can be done.
So this is a very fast
way to replace a product
with a more efficient one and create
a sequestration demand through bamboo.
So that's why I'm very excited
about the potential for this.
The other thing that we have looked at
is how do you get more of the
material out of the forests
and use that in construction.
And so there's a lot of
research going on there
and Sandra did that work when she was
a grad student here, last year.
Let me now move on, to carbon capture
and carbon-to-value real quickly.
So submarines and spacecraft
if you've ever been in one,
in their natural environment,
guess what happens to the co2?
They take it out.
So taking co2 out has been done forever,
you may remember Apollo 13
where one of the canisters
was around and the other was
square and they had a problem,
they were fitting one into the other.
So knowing how to do it,
it's just doing it at scale
and doing it affordably.
But there's two sources, you
can take concentrated co2
and that's out of the smokestack
or you can take it out
of the air which is much harder to do.
So recently the Carbon XPRIZE,
just to give you some hope,
offered a $20,000,000 prize for people
that could take carbon,
from either source,
and converted into something
you could actually sell.
So some examples here, C2CNT,
not cleverest name I ever saw,
it transforms co2 flue
gas into a carbon nanotube
which you can then build into
airplanes wings, for example.
So the carbon is now captured
in a structure that's,
you know, it's a physical
structure that's of value.
Another example here is CAX
which is based in Hayward,
a local example, they convert the gas
to ethylene glycol which is an ingredient
in lithium-ion batteries
and a lot of other things.
Kiverdi takes these
certain type of microbes
add co2 and then convert
it into protein and oils.
So the dream here and it has
to be some amount of reality,
is that there'll be certain markets
that can be figured out,
that can take carbon
either dense at first
and maybe change later
and convert it in the value.
Now my favorite example is
a company called CarbonCure,
they inject co2 as the
cement is being mixed,
that creates...
Here's that chemistry right here.
It takes the calcium and the carbon
and it makes it a solid limestone,
it turns out that means
you need less concrete.
So the cost of using carbon
cure, you can recover
by selling less concrete and
the concrete is stronger.
And now you've taken
co2 that would have been
in the atmosphere and instead
it's in your concrete.
Yes?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
No, that's included in their
process, is to do that.
So there's gonna have to
be some invention here
in these areas, yes.
That's exactly the right question,
exactly the right question.
(students applauding)
There we go.
Okay, how much price on
carbon would have to be
to make one of these
things financially viable?
For some of these things
that we've looked at, it's $30 $40.
It's in the range where an
affordable price of carbon
might trigger our market.
Now California currently
doesn't anticipate this
but you've got this large amounts
of money coming into this.
Something good might
happen out of this process.
Now I realized that that
was the last question
and I'm happy to stick around afterwards
but let me try to summarize
and leave you with a conclusion.
When I started this talk, working on it,
I said well I'll be
depressing but it's the truth
will set you free but I
actually got really excited
after going through all this
of thinking all the things
that can be added into what
we already know how to do
and the fact that we actually have 13,
you know, we have 12 years,
that's a reasonable length of time,
that this could all happen.
So we're going to decarbonize electricity
and electrify everything
we can, that's happening.
There's a company that's announced
an electric pickup truck.
Now the thing about an
electric pickup truck
is it has way more power
than a diesel pickup truck,
huge amounts more, you
can run it all day long
in your garage with the door closed.
I mean it's got all of these advantages.
So you can imagine a scenario
where suddenly the hot
pickup truck and that is the,
you know, that is the
largest selling vehicle
in the United States in any category,
suddenly becomes, you know,
you get the price right.
Who would wanted diesel pickup truck
if you can have an electric one.
Oh, you would like a diesel pickup truck?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
I'm sorry ma'am you'll have
to give me your book (laughs).
What?
(background noise drowns other sounds)
Yeah, the Ford F-150, yeah.
So we're gonna decarbonize liquid fuels,
it's another target behind this.
We have to expand natural
system sequestration,
forest lands, agricultural
lands, whatever,
that's where a lot of
the work is shifting,
is how do you do that in a way
that's really going to work.
We have to scale electric
vehicles at four times
the rate we're currently doing.
And then we have to start figuring out
how to take carbon and convert
it into something, a value.
We need a receptive
federal government by 2021
which will be elections
and in that timeframe
will bring big oil to the table.
So that's my path to success.
I can take questions after we adjourn
but let me show you...
There's always this
small chance that maybe
we forgot something and all this
is gonna self-correct
automatically by nature.
What happens then?
Well, what if it's a big hoax
and we create a bigger
better world for nothing?
(students laughing)
I can live with that, I hope you can too.
Thank you very much.
(students applauding)
(bright music)